Welcome to the DDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk, but uh if you have
questions, you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audience.
Therefore, no classified discussion is
allowed, so please watch out. And
finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now, let me briefly
introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr. Aditi
Krishnapriyan, who is an assistant
professor at UC Berkeley, where she is a
member of Berkeley AI Research,
Electrical Engineering and Computer
Science, and Chemical Engineering.
Her research interests include
physics-inspired
machine learning methods, geometric deep
learning, inverse problems, and
development of machine learning methods
informed by physical sciences
applications, including including
molecular dynamics and fluid mechanics.
A former DOE Computational Science
Graduate Fellow, she holds a PhD from
Stanford University and in
and in 2020 to 2022 was the Luis Alvarez
Fellow in Computing Sciences at Lawrence
Berkeley National Laboratory. Today,
Aditi will talk about bridging numerical
methods and deep learning with
physics-constrained differential
solvers. I'm sure she's going to give us
a a fantastic talk, so please have a
high expectations.
But before I pass the button to Aditi,
let me ask a
you know, one questions as usual as a
tradition of this DDPS seminar. So, my
question is for you, Aditi, is um I
happen to know
one of your hobby is uh translating your
your language from one language to the
another language. How
my Why is that a hobby? That's my
question. And
what kind of language do you uh usually
translate from, you know, to, you know,
what what what other language? Yeah.
Oh, yeah. I'm uh I'm just generally
interested in uh different language
families and bridges between different
language families, which tend to also be
informed by migration patterns. So,
looking at completely different areas of
the world and seeing um what the
overlaps are in language families is uh
just a fun hobby to work on. And it's
gotten quite interesting now, especially
with some of the LLMs and a lot of the
improvement in um in translation.
Oh, that's awesome. And And that's kind
kind of related to your the title of
your talk today.
The bridging numerical methods and the
deep learning. Yes. So, you like you
like to preach.
Okay.
Store stage is yours.
Great. Uh yeah, thanks a lot for the
invitation and the introduction. Uh I
was uh looking forward to giving this
talk because I think a lot of the themes
here, my impression is that they are
going to overlap a lot with uh the
backgrounds of people in the audience,
which could be a mix of applied math, uh
machine learning, physics, and so on. Um
and so,
this is going to just be a general
overview of what we can get from
numerical methods that we've known for a
long time, and a lot of the more modern
machinery in deep learning that has
obviously seen a lot of success, um
especially in the last uh decade or so.
So, So, a lot of this talk and a lot of
uh the research that we work on is
really motivated by this big question of
machine learning potential in modeling
scientific systems.
And more specifically, a lot of these
problems I think come down to how well
you can model spatial and temporal
behavior.
So, whether it's something like modeling
fluid dynamics or some type of weather
patterns or even when you're looking at
molecular systems, how did the atoms
move over time? These are really all
underlying represented by modeling
spatial and temporal behavior of those
systems.
And I think there's so many applications
where this is actually a pretty
challenging task where we have some
really complex phenomena. We want to
really understand all of the intricacies
of that spatiotemporal behavior. And by
doing so, I think this really unlocks a
lot of insights in many, many different
fields of science.
So, I'll briefly talk about what I think
are some of the advantages that neural
networks can offer for physical
modeling. I think these can be a
powerful tool to assist us in this task
while also keeping in mind some of the
limitations or some of the things that
we have to just know
a priori or account a priori when we're
developing these methods.
So, the the first point and one of the
big advantages here is after you train a
neural network, when you actually go and
test it or you do inference on new
problems, this is quite cheap because
you've amortized the computation during
training.
And neural networks, as we as we've seen
time and time again, they're really,
really good at approximating
high-dimensional functions. And this
starts to become really nice when we're
trying to solve these scientific
problems that are very high-dimensional
problems and may have complicated
solutions or ways to get to complicated
solutions.
At the same time, I think there's also
some things to keep in mind,
particularly with neural networks in the
context of scientific computing. So, how
do they actually compare to these
current mechanistic models or even
experiments in a lab? So, there's always
going to be this cost of training, this
cost of data generation, and because we
have these nice models we've developed
for many, many decades that came before
neural networks, I think it's important
to keep in mind these models themselves
at the same time as we're developing new
methods that are going to bring in this
idea of machine learning.
And the other point here, another thing
to keep in mind is the accuracy point.
So, it's not very useful if a neural
network is really fast, but it converges
quickly to the wrong answers. Since this
is again something really important for
scientific modeling that we want
something that is going to be in a
decent ballpark that's going to be at
least a good initial guess to getting us
to the right solutions.
And then finally, I think this other
point, again important for scientific
modeling, is this idea of reliability in
methods. So, a lot of the numerical
methods that have been developed over
the decades have really very strict
reliability criteria or have been really
stress tested to ensure some level of
reliability. And so, can we actually
keep that in mind when we're bringing in
this component of machine learning into
these problems?
And so, I'll start with a really example
common scenario, and this is really
going to be the the basis of the rest of
this talk as I describe some of the
methods that we've been working on now
that go beyond some of these common
scenarios or some of these more toy
examples.
And in this example, this is some type
of damping pendulum. So, you might have
some training data in the early part of
this trajectory, and your goal is to
predict the later dynamics of this
system. And this could be governed by
this very simple PDE. So, this is a
really toy example.
So, if you train a neural network on
predicting only the points in your
training data, so you train it by
minimizing this loss function to match
those training data points, you can see
that it doesn't do very well when it's
trying to predict the later time steps,
even though it gets the early time steps
that it's seen before uh quite well,
which is what we would expect.
But one approach here that I think
uh many of you will be very very
familiar with is this idea that you
could add that underlying ODE, or
possibly an underlying PDE, as a soft
constraint to the neural network loss
function, and you essentially optimize
over this. So, you have that training
data, but then you since you have some
form of the differential equation, this
could be some type of conservation law,
you add that to the loss function, and
you essentially enforce that over all of
the later points in the domain. And when
you train with both of these objectives,
you can see that in this case it seems
like it's actually fitting the later
dynamics because you were giving some
implicit information, some
self-supervisor auxiliary information
about the later time steps.
And this is very colloquially known as
this physics-informed neural network
loss, where you have these physical laws
that are enforced over points in the
domain, so some discretization.
So, the the one thing about this type of
approach, on one hand it's potentially a
way to deal with limited data, or if you
have some type of conservation laws
you'd like to enforce, it's potentially
one way to try to add in that type of
information.
But I think in as maybe many of you have
dealt with, if you train some of these
models, adding the physical laws this
way doesn't necessarily guarantee the
convergence or correct solution or
enforcement of those laws. And often it
takes a lot more beyond that to actually
get some type of convergence property.
And this is just a simple example of
uh a convection problem where you have
just this 1D PDE. Uh as you increase
this wave speed parameter, you can see
that this type of training doesn't
converge very well to the later time
steps. So the left-hand side is this
actual solution and the right-hand side
is what would happen when you train the
model and then predict with this
solution.
So that brings us to
yeah.
I just did there's a question on uh
slide seven. Do you want to answer that
first?
Oh, sure. Uh I actually can't uh see the
screen uh
Yeah, what what would So So what
um Pearson asked, what would happen if
you only gave the first data point, but
then enforced the PDE constraint? Would
it solve the PDE?
Yes, if you only gave this initial
condition up here and then predicted the
rest of the PDE.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it really depends on the
problem setting. I think in a very
simple problem setting like this one, I
think that would work fine if you just
gave the initial condition and then just
optimized over the rest of the PDE. So
you might not even need those training
data points in the first place. But this
setting doesn't uh
do super well when you go to harder
problem settings. If you just do this
kind of ad hoc approach and so One
example here is that in this case um
only the training was done by only
giving the initial condition and the
boundary conditions and then predicting
a solution over the rest of the domain.
Um and as you can see in this case,
especially when you have very sharp
features in your solution, this becomes
a lot harder to capture.
Yes.
I I hope that answered the Pearson's
questions.
If not, Pearson, um speak up.
Or let's move on.
Okay, then feel free to ask questions uh
throughout the talk.
So, that brings me to one of the uh the
main uh idea of this talk, which is
really this idea of how do we resolve
some of these underlying issues when we
try to solve PDEs with machine learning.
And there's a few key points here, I
think, to keep in mind.
So, one of those points is that this
idea of physical consistency or having
an accurate solution, this is especially
important at inference, so at test time
when we actually want to go use the
neural network for some type of task or
deploy it for some type of task. And the
current approaches um that I've
mentioned, whether it's data-driven or
you add this self-supervised PDE loss,
there's no guarantee of those physical
laws being obeyed at test time in
particular. And so, that's potentially
posing a problem for how you would
actually reliably deploy this.
The the other point is that these so far
are all grid-based methods. So, this
means that uh your solution is over some
type of discretized domain.
And that means that you could have some
type of error that comes up because
there's uh some inherent error in that
discretization. And it can also be
expensive because if especially if
you're training with some type of PDE
loss, it requires differentiating um
back through that if you're going to
take derivatives if you have higher
order derivatives in your loss. And if
your architecture is more complicated,
that can start to get expensive to
train.
And there's also some other points here.
So, sometimes um if you have some type
of physical law and it's only
approximately enforced, so this soft
constraint added to the loss function,
this can sometimes be hard to optimize
over and tricky to actually get to
converge. And again, you have that first
issue that this type of approach doesn't
guarantee any convergence at test time.
And all of these issues all become
particularly noticeable in limited data
settings. So, when you don't have a lot
of data, each of these issues really
comes up again and again and becomes a
bigger and bigger problem.
So, the general theme of this talk is
really going to be about this idea of
numerical methods that have been really
successful historically at modeling
complex systems.
And machine learning that's been very
fast and successful at these prediction
tasks in a lot of different areas. How
do we take both of these and get the
best of both worlds when we develop the
next set of methods for scientific
modeling problems?
And both of these have their
limitations, too. So, numerical methods
can be quite slow. Machine learning can
be hard to get accurate or hard to
generalize to new problems. And so,
we're all hoping that by taking the best
of both worlds, we can also limit the
actual limitations of both of these
approaches.
And by combining both, the goal is
perhaps we can get better accuracy with
less data as well as more robust methods
downstream.
And so, the approaches that I'll talk
about are some of the things that we've
been thinking about and working on for
exploring this intersection between
numerical methods and neural networks.
So, the the And for most of this talk, I
think that I'll talk about is solving
PDEs that represent some type of complex
system.
So, in this case, this is an example of
Navier-Stokes equations. You might have
some initial conditions like an initial
vorticity. And your goal is to predict
the spatiotemporal behavior of this
system over time.
And in these cases, because these are
spatiotemporal phenomena or fluid
problems that we know a little bit
about, we can sometimes know that this
might have some type of conservation of
momentum, it might have some type of
conservation of mass and so on.
So the first issue I talked about with
this idea that physical laws are not
imposed at test time, and this can be
when it matters most to have that
physical consistency.
And this can also be sometimes be useful
to enforce these laws at training time
because that ends up actually improving
convergence. This ends up that helping a
lot especially in limited data settings.
And so the first solution I'll talk
about is implementing PDE constrained
optimization as a layer in a neural
network to tackle some of these issues.
So before the neural network setup
looked something like this where you
have some spatiotemporal points in your
domain, you use a neural network to
predict the solution.
And you could train to either matching
the solution loss over your domain. You
could also add this differential
equation loss for the PDE, so this soft
constraint approach.
And then to train a neural network, we
would back propagate through this loss
function with respect to the weights of
the neural network. And after we train
the neural network, we can go test it on
new problems.
As mentioned before, there are some
potential issues with this approach.
And so the thing that we try to do
instead is actually looking at can we
have more control over these physical
laws and enforcing these physical laws?
And to do so, we developed this
framework to add a PDE constrained
optimization layer to a neural network
architecture. So this is a high-level
overview, but I'll go into some of them
important pieces and and details.
And in this case, this PDE constrained
optimization layer can be added on top
of any neural network architecture.
So, the problem setting here is
essentially differential operator
learning where we're trying to find some
operator that maps some parameters here
to some solutions U
such that that conservation law or that
operator is enforced and we know that
it's going to be equal to zero.
So, what we do here is we take a neural
network. So, this is a neural network F
parameterized by some theta
and we want to map the neural network
the parameters of your physical system
to B which is a set of N basis
functions. So, our neural network is
trying to do this parameter mapping.
And we formulate this instead as we want
to find some omega such that when you
take this product of those basis
functions with respect to omega, this is
going to satisfy whatever your
conservation law is. So, this
equivalency is trying to make an
approximation to your solution U.
And so, what we do is we solve for this
omega value using some type of iterative
non-linearly squares solver. So, this
could be LM, it could be Gauss-Newton or
whatever your favorite solver is and
this is done by sampling a set of
spatiotemporal points on your domain.
And after we solve this problem, the
final solution operator prediction is
reconstructed together
with having solved for a reasonable
value of omega with your numerical
solver. And so, you're then having some
approximation for the solution using
this approach instead. So, this is
giving you a bit more precise control
over actually enforcing this
conservation law because you're
explicitly using a solver to try to
actually approximate that PDE
constrained optimization problem.
So, when you look at this setting, I
went through essentially what's a
forward pass of the neural network.
But the issue is that when you run that
solver, so you project your outputs of
the neural network onto some solver, and
that's the solver that you're running to
now actually learn the the PDEs more
precisely. The issue is that when you
take all of these steps of your solver,
you still have to train the neural
network somehow, and doing standard
backpropagation where you differentiate
back through all of those steps is
really expensive. It's actually usually
impossible because you run out of memory
very quickly.
And so to get around this issue, what we
did instead is um so we looked at this
problem, and we see that what we want to
do is the solver is run after the neural
network to come to a solution. And if we
want to actually train the neural
network, we need to differentiate back,
and we need to do some type of gradient
descent on theta, our neural network
parameters, to learn what the correct
solution is.
And so we use uh implicit function
theorem and implicit differentiation,
which I think is a really powerful tool
when you're doing anything with
combining numerical methods and neural
networks. And what that does is you can
formulate this differentiation problem
in an implicit way. So what that means
is that you don't need to differentiate
back through all the steps of your
solver. So you don't have to
backpropagate through the whole
computational graph that got you to that
final point. You can just differentiate
the last step and bypass all of those
intermediate steps.
And a lot of the details you can check
out uh the the paper for a lot of the
details on the full uh framework and the
exact problem that you're solving, but
this is essentially the trick that makes
it possible to combine these two things
together.
So coming back to this and the full
problem setup, so now we have this
neural network architecture. We project
onto this PDE-constrained optimization
layer, which solves the optimization
problem more precisely that represents
our conservation laws. We use implicit
differentiation to train the model. So,
what it means is that the forward pass
of the neural network is decoupled from
the backward pass of the neural network,
and that allows us to train this whole
thing end-to-end with both the neural
network and the solver.
And this means that the neural network
is able to get direct feedback from the
solver, so the weights can update based
on this exact solve that happens in the
PDE constraint optimization layer.
And then at test time, we can go ahead
and run this neural network on a new
problem. And because the forward pass of
the neural network still goes through
this layer here, it means that those
constraints are more precisely enforced
at test time as well.
So, here's a very simple example of uh
when we first tried this out. So, this
was for a Darcy flow problem, uh very
simple PDE where you have some PDE
parameters, in this case uh diffusion
coefficients, and you want to learn what
the PDE solution is.
And so, we ran this with uh a baseline
of we just add the conservation laws to
the loss function, this soft constraint
approach, which uh does does okay, but
it doesn't uh
really converge that well, and it sort
of uh uh plateaus at this point.
And our new model, where we implement
this new layer, which is acts more like
a hard constraint, and you can see that
it starts at a much lower point and then
continues to go down. And this is on
some unseen uh test set, so we just
track how well it's doing during
training on this test set. So, it does
tend to converge more quickly for a
problem like this.
But, that being said, uh I mentioned
that during training, you're going
through this new layer
and differentiating it, but also during
test time, you also have to go through
that new layer.
And what that means is that as you
enforce this layer and this whole setup
on more and more points, which can
happen uh or is quite necessary when
your problem gets quite hard. That also
means that your computational expense
and memory cost increases. So, this is
an example of solving
the 2D Navier-Stokes equations. So, as
we increase the number of sampled
points, it's likely that the model does
better because it's able to
solve for a larger domain and force
whatever physical laws over a larger
domain.
But, the issue is that as you increase
these points, both your training and
your inference time get larger and
larger. So, there's this limitation of
the computational trade-off. And if you
sample more points in this setup, you
often need to have a lower batch size
because of the memory costs, and that
ends up actually hurting training
stability. So, for some of these much
harder problems, it becomes very
difficult to to solve with this current
setup.
So, to get around that setting, we used
a mixture of experts approach to
actually scale this full
architecture. And mixture of experts
really has made it possible to scale a
lot of very large models in many other
fields of machine learning like NLP and
vision.
And it's this nice way of actually
increasing the capacity of the neural
network, but still balancing the
computational expense. Where now you
split the computation over a bunch of
different experts that solve these
different sub-domain problems. And so,
we wanted to see if we could actually
bring this idea of mixture of experts to
our physical modeling problem and
actually be able to scale it to much
harder systems.
So, we framed this PDAE constrained
optimization problem in our neural
network as a mixture of experts instead.
And the main difference is before we had
this neural network, this f of theta,
and we would go ahead and go straight to
the end here and run our solver, do our
prediction. And this time, we actually
split our
our domain into a bunch of different
subdomains and use an expert to solve
the problem along each subdomain.
So, what that fully looks like is you
have some type of neural network here.
We use a
neural operator for this type of
problem. It doesn't matter which
architecture you use though. It could be
your favorite one.
And this whole part here is our PDE
constrained optimization layer. And to
scale it up, we do this domain
decomposition where we have a bunch of
different subdomains. And we enforce
this constrained optimization problem
over each subdomain. So, these are the
hard constraints that are enforced over
these subdomains by the different
experts. And so, this makes those
constraints localized and it's split
across multiple experts here. So, it's
not just one single one, but many
different ones.
And the advantage of this is that now
we've actually decomposed our domain and
we can actually solve this problem in
parallel. So, when we put it all
together, if we have some PDE domain,
I've kept it very simple here just a 2D
problem, but we also do this on 3D and
4D settings. You can give this PDE
domain to the neural network and it'll
go through this whole process of you
have these learnable basis functions
here.
You evaluate and partition them over
your subdomains.
You have this mixture of expert setting
where each expert locally solves the
problem.
And so, it looks something like this
where within each expert, you're still
doing that same task of finding a set of
omega that satisfies this
product here and actually satisfies the
PDE of interest. So, it's the local
constraint over each subdomain.
And then you can go ahead and reassemble
your full predicted solution together.
And then putting it all together, you go
ahead and differentiate your output and
and you use implicit function theorem to
actually train the full model end to
end. And when you do this, that means
that each expert is
both being used in the forward pass, but
also in the backward pass through this
implicit differentiation technique. So
this allows you to actually scale the
model and train it over a lot of
different problems because everything
can also be done in parallel now.
So as an example of what that looks
like, this is this is a problem
diffusion absorption problem. It's a
tricky problem actually because it has a
singularity at a certain point here. And
this is what the numerical solver
solution would look like.
And if you're using a soft constraint
approach,
because of some of those difficulties,
you can see here that in a lot of cases
it's not really able to converge to
any solution.
So when we use our initial approach
where we just have a hard constraint, we
start to do a little bit better, but I
think it's limited to some extent
because you need to sample a lot of
points for this problem. And because we
can't fit all of those points, we often
have to use a lower batch size, so it
actually hurts our training stability.
But when we go ahead and scale this with
this new mixture of experts approach, we
get a lot closer to what the true
solution should be, so it starts to
match the numerical solution pretty
well.
Another advantage is this idea of
lacking training stability. So when we
actually train with our regular
layer with no mixture of experts, it's
not doing super well because of the fact
that during training it's unstable and
it's not just because of this limitation
that it can't sample enough points
because of computational expense.
But when you actually
then train with this MOE setting, this
is another sample that was pulled out of
the system. So we we had a test set of a
few hundred samples. In this case, when
you actually train with that MOE
setting, you're a lot more stable and
predictable when you're doing the
training. So, it's converging slowly to
the right solution in a more stable way.
And then when we come back to this plot
where we
saw that one of the limitations before
was that as you increase the number of
points, your training and inference time
gets slower and slower. In this case
now, when you increase the number of
points, this scales sublinearly. So,
this is a lot more efficient. And I
think this is quite important because as
we get to the whole point of neural
networks is to be faster than numerical
solvers. And at inference time in
particular, if running a neural network
is slower than running a numerical
solver, there's not really much of an
advantage to the neural network
approach. So, getting this down to some
level of
computational efficiency and speed, I
think is very important for actually the
whole purpose of using neural networks.
So, we'll come back to some of these
underlying issues that we looked at
earlier about resolving solving PDEs
with machine learning. And the second
big issue I had mentioned was this idea
that grid-based methods introduce
errors. So, when you solve for a
solution over a discretized domain,
that's going to inherently introduce
some errors.
And so, one solution that we thought of
when we looked at this problem was again
an idea of taking spectral methods,
which have been really successful, used
quite well in applied mathematics and
scientific computing, and seeing if we
could take the advantages of spectral
methods and combine that with the
advantages of neural networks.
So, coming back to this setting of this
physics-informed neural network loss, so
this would be like a self-supervised
setting for solving PDEs. So, when you
optimize over this PDE residual in loss
function, there's this first point that
you're optimizing over physical points
in your domain. So, those grid-based
methods introduce errors. It can also
require a large number of sampled
points. So, if your problem is hard, you
may need a lot of points to optimize
over. And so, this approach also just
has issues with scaling to to large grid
sizes.
And finally, if you're looking at this
setting where you're using a neural
operator and then optimizing over it
with some type of PDE loss, this can be
expensive to differentiate back through
the architecture, especially for more
complicated architectures like the
Fourier neural operator.
It means that some of the scaling
actually doesn't do super well,
especially if you have higher-order
derivatives that you're trying to
enforce.
So, spectral methods have been very
powerful for solving PDEs. So, these
basis function expansions, you could use
Chebyshev polynomials as one example.
You could use Legendre polynomials. They
can be quite powerful and efficient. And
when you're learning PDEs in in the
spectral representation, you can really
do accurate approximations of
differentiation and integration, or you
can really do accurate approximations of
algebraic operations. Going out to a
certain when you go to out to a certain
number of terms when you do that basis
expansion.
And so, I think these have a lot of
potential to also think about how they
can be integrated with neural networks
because there are so many advantages of
these methods in the scientific
computing setting.
And so, to
take the ideas from spectral methods and
neural networks and really get the best
of both worlds,
we came up with this neural spectral
methods approach where we have in our
base architecture some type of spectral
base neural operator. It's not just
limited to Fourier basis, so you can
actually use Chebyshev polynomials or
Legendre polynomials, like really any
spectral basis function. And we actually
find that for a lot of the problems we
look at, using Chebyshev basis actually
works a lot better than a Fourier basis,
particularly in cases where you don't
have a periodic boundary conditions as
what you would expect for when you see
how where they're used in scientific
computing.
And we also have this spectral loss
function, and I'll go through each of
these. And this is in contrast to this
idea of physical space learning that had
some of the limitations mentioned before
that it could be harder to learn and you
have these grid size limitations.
So, we start in this case in our base
architecture by having we have our
parameters to solutions. This is the
same setting that we want to learn. And
we look at the spectral representation
of our parameters.
We do these spectral transformations, so
this is where we're we're deciding what
basis functions we want to use. In this
case, Chebyshev polynomials
tend to be the the ones that end up
working quite well.
And then, for the last point, we use the
spectral training procedure where we can
actually use Parseval's identity to come
up with an equivalency between some type
of PDE loss in your physical domain and
what that spectral representation is
because you can have this equivalency
through the sum of the square of your
spectral coefficients. And that
essentially gives you a very good
approximation for what the PDE residual
of the problem is. And what that means
is that you can actually not just
project to spectral space and do all of
the your architecture transformations in
this part of the architecture, you can
then train the whole model fully in
spectral space by using the spectral
loss function.
And that allows you to just do
everything in the spectral domain, uh
which will have some advantages as I'll
talk about now.
But just a quick note is that this is in
contrast to training in the physical
domain if you have some grid-based
neural operator and you have this uh PDE
loss or this physics-informed neural
network loss. So this would be uh so the
top part is
the spectral approach in contrast to
this physical approach.
So here's one example where we looked at
a reaction-diffusion system. So in this
case we have um this is uh just a 2D
problem. You have some temporal
dimension and some spatial dimension.
And we ran a numerical solver on this.
So you see that it behaves very
predictably.
As you increase the resolution of your
domain, the error gets lower and lower.
And this error is relative to a very
fine discretization. So we generated a
really fine solution and then we
subsampled it to represent all of these
different grid points.
So if you use this approach of a
standard grid-based neural operator and
you add
and then you add some type of uh PDE
loss to that. So this would be training
only in physical space. You can see that
uh it doesn't quite match up super well.
So it's slower with the finer
discretization.
And one thing is that you can see that
it actually overfits a little bit to the
training grid that it was trained on. So
it actually sometimes will do worse for
higher training grids rather than uh
decrease continuously like this uh
standard numerical solver. So this would
be like the the grid-based approaches.
And in contrast, when you do this all in
the spectral domain, so you use the
approach I talked about where you have
this neural network, you train it with a
spectral loss,
you end up down here for all of your
grid sizes because now the grid no
longer matters because your
computational cost is uh constant
regardless of the grid size because
you're not actually not expressing your
loss function in terms of the grid
itself. So, there's no sampling issue
here.
And you can see that it maintains
accuracy. So, when you compare it to the
standard numerical solver, it's faster
for the same level of accuracy, which I
think is the comparison that we should
be doing for all new neural network
methods in this ML for PDEs space.
We also went and looked at different
forms of the Navier-Stokes equations.
So, this is an example where we're
looking at unforced Navier-Stokes
equations where the top row is our
numerical solver. The middle row is our
method and the bottom row is when you
train only in physical space. So, this
is actually an animation, but we
converge pretty quickly with the
spectral approach. Whereas, when you
look at the bottom row, there's a lot of
features here that just don't converge
to what the numerical solver looks like
and these are somewhat hard to resolve.
And this is another example where now we
look at forced Navier-Stokes equations.
So, we have this numerical solver. We
train only in physical space and this
actually blows up over long time scales.
So, the error gets really high as you
get further and further away in time.
And when you do this approach with
spectral methods, it's a lot more
well-behaved. So, over time the total
relative error ends up being a lot
lower.
And I didn't plot the computational
speed here, but that's also a very big
advantage of this approach that it's a
lot faster both during training, but
also when you actually go and use this
model during inference.
So, the last thing I'll talk about is so
far I've talked about this idea of
inspiration for numerical methods and
neural networks in the context of
solving PDEs, so fluid dynamics problems
or other general types of PDEs. But I
think these simulation in the loop ideas
can also be really relevant for other
problems like molecular systems or
things at the atomistic scale and
running molecular dynamics.
So this is an approach here where
the way you train models for molecular
dynamics, a very common approach is that
you try to approximate the potential
energy surface of these systems. And if
you have a good approximation for the
energies and the forces, you can then
run these simulations over time by using
a numerical integrator and hopefully you
can run it for very long time scales
without running into instabilities
because then you can study the system
better. You can compute observables
about the system from that type of
simulation.
But there are also some challenges here.
So this is an example of a neural
network trained for these molecular
simulations and we go ahead and run this
over in time. So we simulate the system
over ideally long time steps.
And initially it seems okay, but as you
simulate the system larger longer and
longer, you see that there's this very
clear unphysical thing happening where
there's this bond stretching that
results in very unstable structure. And
both what that means is that so you
can't really trust the simulation
because there are these instabilities
coming up, but any types of properties
that you then want to compute from that
simulation are probably going to be very
inaccurate because the simulation is
just not stable enough to get to the
point of where you can do those
computations.
So coming back to the idea of simulation
in the loop, there's a lot of learning
signal that you can get from the
molecular simulation itself. So in this
case
this approach
is a slightly different problem setting
that you might have some atomistic
system, some molecular system. You give
it to a neural network and you predict
the energies and the forces of that
system. And once you have the forces,
you can use numerical integration to get
to your next time step, and this is how
you would run the simulation over time.
And as you run this MD simulation over
time, and keep running it, you can
compute system observables about that
system. So, something about that system,
or multiple properties of that system.
And so, typically the common approach to
train these models is to train this
neural network to just the energies and
forces. But in this case, we wanted to
actually train the neural network to the
simulation itself. So, actually use all
of this information of the simulation,
and build that into the training
procedure somehow. Because that would
also then allow us to train to more than
just energies and forces. We could
actually train to observables of the
system. Maybe those observables come
from experiment. So, this could be
actually a way to bridge some type of
theory-experiment gap, as well.
And so, the same idea here is when we go
and train to these observables over MD
simulation. So, we run the MD
simulation, we query the neural network,
run the integrator. We compute system
observables,
and we take a loss function on the
observables. Now, we come into the same
issue that we had before, where you
can't differentiate back through all of
the steps of your MD simulation, because
it means that you're going to
differentiate through all of the steps
of your numerical integrator.
And so, instead here, we can do the same
thing. We can train the neural network
with implicit differentiation. So,
there's actually a way it's a different
approach to formulate this implicit
differentiation problem than the
previous approach I talked about,
because this is actually a stochastic
setting. So, you're actually doing
implicit differentiation over a
distribution.
But the key idea here is that you can
formulate
taking the gradients this way. And the
key insight is really that you separate
getting that out the neural network
output from the rest of the neural
network itself. So, you don't have to
back propagate back through all of the
steps of the solver to get there.
And so, this ends up also being uh quite
powerful in the context of molecular
dynamics. So, this is an example of uh a
water system and there's a local
instability that comes up. So, the full
simulation in the loop method uh and the
differentiation technique we call this a
Boltzmann estimator because we formulate
the implicit differentiation problem
based on the fact that we know that the
underlying system obeys a Boltzmann
distribution. And this is how you can
actually formulate what the
differentiation task should be.
And so, before training, when you use
standard training uh so, the approach uh
over here where you just train it with
these energies and forces,
when you run this system uh over time
over all of these picoseconds, all of
the trajectories become unstable
relatively quickly. So, often too
quickly before you can actually compute
things that are of interest, so
observables of interest about the
system.
But when you actually now train it in
the simulation in the loop style after
we do our training procedure,
uh we can actually simulate this system
for we went all the way we went up to uh
1 nanosecond, but you can also go
further than that. Then, you can see
that the system no longer has the same
instability problems as before.
And the way that this nicely manifests
is that if we then want to go and
actually compute things from the system,
so in this case, we don't train it on
anything about the diffusivity
coefficient. So, it doesn't see anything
about this. But after we train it with
this procedure and we go run it at test
time and we compute the diffusivity
coefficient of the system,
we end up being a lot closer to what the
true coefficient is. So, this black line
here represents the reference. And
before training, all of these uh before
our training, the trajectories were not
really getting any close to the those
reference observables. And after our
training, we're a lot more in the
ballpark or in the general range of what
that true diffusivity coefficient should
be.
And so, I think this type of procedure
is powerful for both bridging this
theory and experiment gap, but also the
fact that by doing this procedure, you
can improve both the stability and
performance on new systems or new
observables, and actually have some
level of hopefully more reliability in
running those molecular simulations
downstream. And the the very high-level
general idea of bridging numerical
simulations with neural networks is
still generally true here in this
setting as well.
So, in summary, I think neural networks
do have a lot of potential for these
physical modeling problems.
But at the same time, we really need to
keep in mind this idea that we need
accurate and rigorous methods that are
going to be able to give us reliable,
physically consistent answers when we go
run that method in a simulation or go
run that neural network in a simulation.
And this idea of also having trust
during deployment. So, after we train a
model, we would like to trust it when we
actually go use it for a lot of
different downstream tasks.
And so, here I talked about a few
different examples of the best of both
worlds. So, taking numerical methods and
deep learning and putting these together
with this idea of differentiable
solvers. So, ways to actually come up
with differentiation techniques that let
you train these two things together. So,
whether that's through this idea of a
PDE constraint optimization layer in the
neural network,
or taking neural networks and combining
them with spectral methods ideas, uh Uh,
as well as the fact that these
simulation and the loop ideas also
extend to problems like molecular
dynamics where it's a bit of a different
setting because you have a stochastic
setting, but you can still formulate the
same differentiation approaches and
train this model uh, to the output of a
simulation itself and ideally improve
the simulation stability as well as the
accuracy of the properties that you
compute from that simulation.
And uh, the the papers with
all the code available for everything I
talked about are all down here. So, you
can uh, definitely go check it out and
uh, let us know if you have any
questions.
And finally, I I'd like to thank uh, a
lot of the great students that I get to
work with. So, a lot of the work I
talked about here was with Yihang,
Nitin, and Sanjeev on all of these uh,
different areas.
And I'll go ahead and come back to this
summary slide and happy to take any more
questions as well. Thanks.
Awesome. Awesome. Thank Thank you so
much for the wonderful for talk. Very
nice.
Okay. Um, there there were questions um,
during your talk. Uh, so the first
question is by Dijel.
Uh, she wants to uh, know about what
kind of neural network you used in slide
eight.
Oh, sure.
Let me uh,
I I think that's when you talk about the
PINs.
Oh, the Oh, yeah. I think slide eight
um, Yeah, that was just the toy example
setting uh,
in
in that setting, it was just a simple
MLP for that problem. Um,
but in some of the later
uh, methods settings I showed, uh, we
used a few different types of neural
operator architectures. Um, but the
methods I was talking about, a lot of
them are agnostic to the underlying
architecture. Uh, but in in that uh, toy
example, it was just a just a regular
fully connected neural network.
Okay.
Um
and second question is by Daddy
in slide 45 and 46,
how would the spectral methods work when
the flow has discontinuities?
For example, shock.
Yeah, that's a really good question. Uh
so, how would you solve a problem if
there's any discontinuities? That's
actually uh exactly what we're working
on right now. So, we have some ideas
that there are potentially ways that you
could parameterize uh your domain with
uh maybe like using something analogous
to finite element methods, and that
would at least help with the fact that
uh you would have discontinuities in
your domain. I think it's a really good
uh and a very important problem,
especially if you're looking at systems
with complex or varying geometries.
Okay. Next question is by Sakar. Um
he has a bunch of questions. So, do you
mind, Sakar, unmute yourself and then
ask that question yourself?
If not, I I I can ask. Okay, his first
question is is there a reference for
implicit different differentiation
applied to these applications?
Uh the neural networks and the numerical
solvers. That's his first question.
Yeah, for these um there are some some
of the
earlier work in this area, there was um
this idea of OptNet or optimization as a
layer, which was this very general
approach that maybe you could
incorporate some type of optimization
problem into neural networks. Um and
there's also been uh
approaches like using the adjoint
method, though that's not I think quite
in the same flavor as a lot of the work
that I talked about here. And the
adjoint method actually can have
numerical instability problems that
don't uh come up in the same way for uh,
in the settings that I talked about
here. For in the context of using
implicit differentiation for uh, for
example, solving PDE problems, uh, I
think the reference would really be like
uh, some of our work here where we
in this first paper, we actually
formulated doing this as a PDE
constrained optimization problem, uh,
and then extended it to the MOE setting.
Okay. And his second question is, can
the computation by each expert in the
MOE method be parallel?
Yeah, exac- exactly. Yeah, it can uh,
definitely be parallelized. So, that's
one of the big advantages that you're
not just splitting solving the problem
on a bunch of different subdomains, but
you can do that computation on the all
of those subdomains in parallel. So,
that's also
one of the reasons there's a big speed
up in doing it with the MOE setting.
Okay. The last question by Zachariah is,
how much faster or slower is the method
MOE compared to a numerical solver for
inference?
Yeah, compared to a numerical solver for
inference, for the settings that we
looked at, so we started looking at uh,
a few different settings,
diffusion-sorption, reaction-diffusion
problems, and Navier-Stokes problems.
With the MOE setting, we are faster than
a numerical solver.
Um, in the original setting that we had,
where we didn't use the MOE, we were
about equal with a numerical solver at
the time. So, the MOE was actually quite
crucial to be faster.
That being said, when we first uh, did
this, there it actually wasn't super
optimized to run these iterative solvers
on GPUs. Um, that operation was actually
not uh, super well, um,
optimized for the in this context of
actually trying to do optimization
directly there, because you have to do
it on the GPUs if you want to train it
with a neural network. Uh, since then
there's been a lot of improvements. So,
I think actually at this point even
without the MOE setting, I think we
actually would be faster than a
the numerical solver for a lot of
problems, but you get a much bigger
speed up in the more practical version
of this is to do it in the MOE setting.
Okay. Next question is by Mike. Is there
a communication in the parallel solve at
the domain boundaries?
Yeah, that's a really good question. So,
how do you deal with the fact that
there's a domain decomposition and there
could be issues between the boundaries.
So, what we actually found there was
that as long as each expert, so each
subdomain solve had the global initial
and boundary conditions, that was
actually enough for it to learn
something reasonable and not have issues
at the boundaries. Before we gave those
global conditions, we were doing some
things like trying to actually have
overlapping domains, like stitching the
boundary conditions, doing some type of
Gaussian smoothing over the boundary
conditions
or over the boundary conditions of the
different domains, but just giving the
global initial and boundary conditions
to each subdomain ended up actually
solving that issue.
Okay. Next question is by Quan Chan.
Nice talk.
You've shown strong advantage of neural
spectral method. Perhaps uh
he missed it, but are there any
deficiencies to the method?
Yeah, so for deficiencies deficiencies
for the method, so I think one was the
point that was brought up earlier. How
do you deal with discontinuities? And so
this is something that we're
like I mentioned, we're actively working
on this and using approaches to actually
deal directly with discontinuities,
especially if you have very
complex domain geometries.
And the so that's one approach. The
other approach is also that sometimes
you might need more frequency modes to
actually really capture the domain
especially for some of these more
complex problems. And so you have to be
careful there because there's that
trade-off of more modes means that you
have some computational inefficiencies.
So it's going to be slower to train the
model or run the model. But that's also
something that we're actively working on
now. And actually
we've already made some speed ups which
will be pushed to this repository pretty
soon that deal with that computational
inefficiency problem.
All right. Quan Chen also asked that
also can you recommend a good reference
paper on MOE theory?
Yeah, for
a good reference paper so the
one of the earlier papers that I think
with the Noam Shazeer from 2017. That's
a good starting point for
one of the earlier examples of something
that worked quite well. But if you want
to go even further to the theory,
there's papers from the '90s that
describe the problem setting. But that
2017 paper is an example of showing it
in action in large-scale machine
learning.
Okay. Uh
Next question is by Mike. If you run the
new approaches, can you show that you
can run these problems out indefinitely
without an instability?
Yeah, so is that in the PDE setting or
like the molecular dynamics setting?
Uh probably PDE setting. I'm I'm sure.
Yeah, PDE. Yes.
Sure. Yeah, so so we haven't tried
running it out
indefinitely so to speak just running it
for
months and months at a time. I think
this does definitely help stabilize the
method so you are able to do these much
longer rollouts. And this is actually
something we've started testing a lot
more now. So we are able to run some of
these Navier-Stokes systems for longer
time scales, but I think this also
comes into as the problem becomes harder
and harder. So, if you have turbulence
flow, for example, you have really high
Reynolds numbers, I think that's where
long time scales becomes hard, and I
think that's actually one of the big
challenges that we should really be
working on with these methods to see how
well we can do that that long time scale
modeling.
Okay.
Next question is by Shutong.
Does the network approximate the
coefficients of the basis function for
the spectral method?
If so, will there be an error when
transforming the field from the physical
domain to the spectral domain? Will this
error propagate during the time domain
evolution?
So, sounds like the question is, so you
have you're operating on spectral
coefficients, and you're training
specifically in spectral space on those
coefficients. So, the the nice thing
about the spectral approach, and I can
go back here. So, this
this identity here, so Parseval's
identity
essentially gives you an exact form of
the PDE residual up to
a certain amount of basis functions, so
whatever you truncate your basis
functions at. And so, by actually and
so, this is computed directly with the
sum of the squares of your spectral
coefficients. And so, because you can
actually do this as an exact
computation, this actually ends up not
really mattering that much because
you've effectively solved for the PDE
residual in a mostly exact way up to a
certain level of basis function
expansions.
And so, that issue doesn't really or we
found that issue doesn't really come up
when we actually use this neural
spectral methods approach on a on a
physical problem, that when you actually
translate this to solving on a physical
grid, it ends up being the either way.
Right. Um
you know, related question by me.
But it is that accuracy of the spectral
method uh neural spectral method is
bounded by the whatever the um the
spectral, you know, the basis you
you're using, right? I mean, it's if if
the spectral basis can capture like
99.9% of your solutions, then you're
stuck with it. That's the the best you
can do.
Right. So, it's So, it is um so, it is
it does depend on what spectral basis uh
set that you use. But we're also
exploiting the fact that as your basis
expansion goes towards infinity, it it
means that you're in theory going to be
able to exactly approximate the
solution.
Yeah, in theory, yes. But then in
practice, you have to truncate at some
point. You cannot go infinity. So, there
will be,
you know, the limitation in accuracy,
how much you can represent with a
spectral
Yeah, so, we So, we found at least um in
the settings I showed and we're now
testing it on harder settings that there
was we didn't have to go uh
towards uh infinity or something uh
to a very, very large number of terms.
Usually, we could go within a reasonable
amount, within a reasonable computation
cost, and get most of the way there.
If If the If there is no shock or
discontinuity in the solutions, yeah.
Right, exactly. If there's no shock or
discontinuity. Um and that uh area now
we're actively working on with a few
other approaches, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, I I another question by me is you
know, um
the nonlinear manifold reduced to the
model like the projection-based reduced
model, but you introduced that nonlinear
manifold, you know, the neural network
kind of basis solution representations.
And you plug that into the, you know,
existing numerical method
and solve for the the latent space
coefficients instead of the full space.
Um you know, so that, you know, you get
the efficiency.
The the method you
you know, introduce so-called the
physics constraint
um
methods um
you know, the first method you
introduced. It it has a very similarity
between those two. The by the fact that
you you do take advantage of the
existing numerical method
and in- instead of the traditional
basis, you use the neural network basis.
Mhm. And then you actually solve that
PDE, right? Um so yeah, so do you are
you So my first question is are you
familiar with that non-linear manifold
with the pseudo model?
Yeah, I'm I'm a bit I'm familiar with
that general area and I I do agree that
I think there is some overlap in that um
I think some of the advantages of both
the approaches I talked about here and
that approach are that you're doing a
change of basis and potentially now
learning in a space that's going to be
easier to learn on than it was before.
Yeah, so but in that projection
basically the pseudo model, you know,
because you're introducing more
non-linearity through the neural network
you just introduced,
it it was not
there before.
So so the complexity of the
non-linearity is has increased.
So because of that, it is very important
to, you know, apply the techniques
so-called hyperreductions there.
Otherwise, you wouldn't get the speed up
um
cuz it's you're uh interacting with the
existing numerical method
and you have increased the non-linearity
in very intertwined way.
So you do need a some special method to
deal with it. I'm wondering if
if for your method
if you need those kind of you know, how
do you handle them the non-linearity you
introduce through the neural network.
Yeah, I think
um
So, I think in practice we haven't seen
that be a a big issue. At at one point
we were using much more complicated
iterative solvers cuz we thought that
that would be the one-to-one between
solving this in a numerical setting and
solving this in the neural network
setting. Um but as long as we just have
a reasonable iterative non-linear least
squares solver, we found that the neural
network would do the rest of the heavy
lifting. Um and so we didn't explicitly
see I think this issue that you're
describing. Um but I think it's
definitely interesting and it would be
worth uh testing out on more cases to
see if this actually explicitly needs to
be dealt with.
Okay.
All right. Well, um
it's 3 minutes after 11:00. So, we're
I think it's a
good time to
uh finish
um our you know, the your seminar. But
thank you so much for the wonderful talk
and um
beautiful introduction of those three
methods and yeah, definitely
um more interested in going to deep and
then learn more about it. So, thank you
so much for
Uh yeah, thanks a lot for all all of the
great uh questions. It was fun to have
so many questions and uh feel free to
contact me afterwards if you wanted uh
talk more or have more questions.
Awesome. Awesome. Thank you, Aditi.
Thanks.